welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down all of the big leaks in
info that we've heard on the upcoming
Mandalorian episode shown at Star Wars
celebration episode 7 sounds like it's
got lots of major things happening in it
throughout this video we're going to be
going over the main points and leaks
from the event obviously heavy spoilers
ahead and with the episode releasing on
Wednesday you might not want to know
anything before we head into it channels
called heavy spoilers are made so I I
don't I don't want to hear anything
about why why did you spoil it when you
spoke shut the up yeah just shut up
oh out of the way thanks for clicking
the video let's get into the Mandalorian
spoilers now according to the rumors
episode 7 will see The Return of none
other than moth Gideon turns out that he
will actually be on Mandalore and this
is where the episode will predominantly
take place if you watch the episode 5
breakdown then you might have seen us
talking about how the intro to the Star
Wars Shona features a red Mandalorian
helmet in it many people thought that
this might just be Mando but we
theorizer because the colors denote blue
for good and red for bad that this was
actually moth Gideon's turns out that's
true as well and will apparently see him
donning a black Mandalorian suit along
with a matching helmet in addition to
this he'll also have praetorian Gods who
will also wear their own best car armor
as well praetorian gods are what we saw
working alongside snoke in The Last Jedi
and they'll apparently have armor now
more in line with the mandalorians due
to the Imperials plundering the planet
now take this with a pinch of salt as I
wasn't able to fully verify because
there's lots of fake leaks floating
around at the moment some people were
even saying that Han Solo made a cameo
in the episode but this has been
debunked so everyone who's telling is
trick in your mate and this is why you
can trust your Uncle Kevin spoilers
unless he's in it and I've been tricked
as well anyway look the gods will
apparently come from the shadow cancel
and this will be led by General hux's
father Brenna doll Brenner doll has
appeared in a lot of the expanded lore
and he's basically charging the
praetorians with protecting Gideon as he
tries to gain a foothold the Mandalore
here is mined the planet and then taken
the best score and given it to these
Gods so that they can make their suits
this will be why the shuttle that
Captain tiva found her traces of it and
there'll be big enemies in the episode
that the Mandos have to fight off
against now it'll turn out that Gideon
has been lying low on the planet for a
while and that the bombers we saw
attacking Bo's Palace will actually
belong to him this moment very much
echoed the night of a thousand tears and
the attack was deliberately carried out
by him as an act of revenge against her
people I'm guessing that the moth was
expecting more of her allies to be there
but obviously they all left quicker than
the audience for this season did
I'm just kidding I I thought it was all
right well not that bit obviously but
it's been all right anyway you've
unsubscribed haven't you we'll get we'll
get back on track now the Ahsoka teaser
also shows the grand entrance of the
grand Admiral drawn is back and though
he won't appear in the episode he will
at the very least get his name dropped
Gideon working for him is another theory
that we had and apparently his name
comes quick and fast with him being
mentioned early on in the seven minute
preview that was shown during the first
big panel at the event we have a big
breakdown of that on the channel and
also if you want to see the first image
of Lars Mickelson is thrawn then head
over to our Instagram at heavy spoilers
which will be linked as the pin comment
copyright is a funny old thing on
YouTube so I don't really want to show
it in the video but it's it's there if
you're interested and also give me a
follow anyway the whole point of
Gideon's missions to rebuild the first
order and will also be apparently
discovering what was happening with the
cloning apparently at one point they
talk about bringing the Empire a new
leader and I think this might be the
moment I wish thrawn is mentioned and if
you read heir to the Empire air then you
know he was very much attempting to
become the new emperor and take over the
whole racket although it apparently
becomes clear in this episode that
they're actually using cloning
technology and this is so they can make
it so somehow Palpatine returned
according to Reddit Gideon walks past
some cloning tubes like what we saw in
season two and we can also see further
developed bodies in them Reddit user J
Vander H said they tried looking in it
but couldn't see who it was because of
it being blurry it did say that it
looked a bit more human than snoke did
though so they might be reintroducing
pulps through using this method now we
will apparently learn that the project
is called project Necromancer so it
makes sense that it centers around
bringing the dead Emperor back to life
now speaking of dead we also get a big
character death happening in this
episode kinda spoiled some of the more
major things but yeah this might be
something that you don't want to know so
again avoid the video from now on heavy
spoilers May the child's course
these spoilers is right there you still
here well the episode apparently has the
death of Paz Vizsla playing out in it
with him dying during battle against the
praetorians according to the leaks this
is gonna be a big glorious death with
his final words being this is the way
I'm not crying you're you're crying now
the episode will also apparently end
with a big Cliffhanger and in this
battle din will get captured I couldn't
work out fully what was said but the
leaks basically went over how he was
wrapped in cables and captured before he
was taken to a debriefing room whether
this is where the shadow council is or
not I don't know but that's basically
what happened with him now other things
that I was able to pass out of this big
spoiler thread is that there's a
gigantic beast on the lava planet that
the mandalorians have to fight I'm
hearing that this is at the midpoint and
that it sets up the big battle that
comes right after it I have seen credit
concept after this and it kind of looked
like a giant worm from that with the
mandalorings fighting it from a metal
platform that I think might be a boat
now there is also some armor that gragu
gets as well if you've been watching our
weekly breakdowns then you'll know that
we brought up there were some leaks that
said Grog who got a mech suit in the
series made out of ig11 this is
apparently true as well with it
basically being the character with his
inside hollowed out in it having grogu
sing in the middle of it when the way it
was described I'm imagining it being
like crying from the Ninja Turtles with
him sitting in the middle and
controlling it from there apparently
he's got two knobs on him like your
girlfriend's dream man and these can be
activated to say either yes or no this
will be how grogu talks in these
episodes with them answering questions
through pressing those buttons anyway
kind of passing things from the comments
on leak thread so well that's fully
accurate and not remains to be seen but
they did mention something along those
lines other miscellaneous things I could
pick up that the episode is titled the
spies and then it runs for about 40-ish
minutes seeing some say 42 and then
others say that it's 50 but that's
including Recaps credits and so on so
yeah it's one of the longer ones from
the season but not a mammoth hour long
entry or anything now apparently the
shadow councils has gilad pallion
connected to it as well whether he
appears on it or not I'm not sure but he
does at least get name dropped as being
part of it with thrawn Palin is a big
name in the expanded lore and in case
you don't know him he commanded them
Imperial Star Destroyer that was called
the harbringer eventually he ended up
joining Throne seventhly as well so
they're very much setting things up for
his appearance as part of the Ahsoka
show I'm really excited for that as well
as the trailer looks awesome and this
episode of the Mandalorian sounds big
too this is pretty much gonna be a major
two part of thing before we head into
the finale and from what people have
been saying after the event this is a
big way to ramp things up but the finale
the week after my another season has
kind of been all over the place and
there have been a lot of rumors that
they try to force too many things into
the series due to Studio interference
according to Josh Hutton of nerds there
were part of the Gina carano's spin-off
show that got pushed into this and
they've steered away from having dinners
the main Mandalorian because they want
to tell more stories involving other
characters in case they conquer Pedro
Pascal back now whether that happens or
not remains to be seen But the creative
team have confirmed that they are
focusing on different characters with
the Mandalorian title being something
that can be changed to apply to other
people that's kind of becoming clear and
obviously I'd love to hear thoughts on
the season so far and what you think of
these leaks comment below and let me
know and just to let you know we are in
competition right now giving away the
Superman 4K box set three subscribers on
the 15th of April all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe and
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the leaks
repeat the comments out random on the
15th and the winners of the last one on
screen right now so the two heavy
spoilers on Twitter if you claim come
and claim your prize if you want
something else to watch them make sure
you check out our breakdown of all the
announcements from the other day which
will be linked on the screen right now
talking about the ray movie talking
about Skeleton Crew and or season two
whatever you want to know it's over
there that video by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace